Speaker 1: There's an interesting new piece to the
Joe Rogan vaccine COVID controversy that I want
to talk about, and it's it's sort of a common
end point that often takes place when someone
makes a bunch of statements or allow statements to
be made and those statements are then scrutinized.
Then it turns out while these statements are
inaccurate, they're potentially dangerous, etc..
There's this common refrain, which is some version
of nobody should really be listening to me about
this topic anyway. And that's where Joe Rogan
has reportedly landed, saying taking advice from
him on vaccines isn't a smart thing to do. And
while it might be funny and it's certainly true,
a lot of the problem comes from this sort of like
moral hazard type scenario. Although moral hazards
not the exact word for it, but but some will
know what I mean. Where those who need to be told
that it's not smart to take their advice on X are
people not smart enough to realize that? And and
that's really sort of what's at issue here. So let
let me back up a little bit and remind you guys.
A podcaster and comedian, Joe Rogan, has been over
the last three weeks or so. I've been under heavy
fire for two different sets of reasons. One comes
with regard to COVID and vaccine disinformation
perpetuated by some of Joe Joe Rogan's guests,
with no disclaimers that what the guests are
saying runs counter not only to the medical
science consensus, but to the empirical realities
of of medical science, as some such
claims have also been made by Rogan
himself. And this led to one controversy
wherein Neil Young and Joni Mitchell and
others pulled their content from Spotify in
protest Spotify, the kind of main platform
for Joe Rogan's podcast separately. But relatedly,
there has also been significant backlash against
Joe Rogan for numerous uses uses of the N-word on
his program over the last decade. Some jokes and
laughing related to sexual harassment and sexual
assault. And so that's another problem. Today,
we're focusing on the vaccine piece, and there's
a new report from media which says Joe Rogan says
people who take the vaccine take vaccine advice
from him are not smart, are not smart. Joe Rogan
made his way back to the standup stage Tuesday
night and addressed the Spotify controversies.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Rogan
headlined a small show in Austin, Texas,
at the Vulcan Gas Company and talked about the
controversies. Speaking about the N-word, he said,
I used to say it if I was talking about a Richard
Pryor bit or something, I would say it in context.
Somebody made a compilation of every time I said
it over 14 years and they put it on YouTube,
and it turned out that was racist as f even to me.
I'm me and I'm watching it saying, stop saying it.
I put my cursor over the video and I'm like, four
more minutes. I haven't used that word in years,
but it's kind of weird. People will get really
mad if you use that word and tweet about it on a
phone that's made by slaves. Rogan then tackled
the other controversy the anti-vax he says,
I talk s for a living. That's why this is so
baffling. If you're taking vaccine advice from me,
is that really my fault? What dumb ass were you
about to do? When my stupid idea sounded better,
you know that dude who made people eat animal
penises on TV? How does he feel about medicine?
If you want my advice? Don't take my advice.
Rogan previously said dozens of celebrities
contacted him for COVID advice, including Aaron
Rodgers and UFC president Dana White. So this
this is the exact problem, guys. The problem
is people are not smart enough to realize
that they should not be taking his vaccine advice.
The people we're worried about is the point, and
that's why it's so concerning, right? If Joe Rogan
was only giving vaccine advice to informed people,
it would essentially have no detrimental effect.
You'll be like, OK, nobody, nobody's taking that
seriously. He's also, by the way, kind of calling
his audience dumb, which is interesting. They may
not realize that that's what he's doing. I don't
know. But but this whole like, come on, guys who
would believe me. It's a very common kind of face
saving tactic for people pushing these narratives.
But at the end of the day, it's really an insult
to his audience. You guys aren't so stupid. You
would listen to me, right? And unfortunately,
the answer is yes. A lot of them are.
A lot of them are, and it's evidenced by the fact
that Dana White is coming to Rogan for advice,
Aaron Rodgers said on other podcasts. When I
got COVID, I talked to Joe Rogan and there's
this entire echo chamber that reinforces the
idea that you would go to him. I think it was.
There's this, Oh man, there's this right wing
Trump supporting podcaster named Tim Poole,
who I guess said, you know, he used to be on
the left, I guess, or something like that.
And when Tim Poole got COVID, he said he called
Rogan. So it's not, you know, it's not only that
Rogan needs to let the audience know, I guess it's
not. You're not smart if you listen to me on this.
There's other people who are then saying, I'm
also going to Rogan for advice on this stuff.
And that's why it's so concerning now that the
fallback of saying your audience is stupid for
listening to you. It's it's interesting for sure.
And it I mean, I don't know what it. I'm not sure
what it suggests about what Joe Rogan thinks about
his own audience, because if Joe Rogan is saying
it's not smart to take advice from me, he must
know lots of people are doing it. What does he
think about his audience? Which is an interesting
question as well, but this is sometimes, you know,
it's it's a version of when Fox News gets sued for
the things that Tucker Carlson says on his show.
The lawyers for Fox say Carlson is an entertainer
who engages in hyperbole. He's not saying things
that should be taken as fact, he's not a
reporter, but the whole shtick with Fox is
report opinions and frame and package this stuff
as if it is someone telling you these are facts.
But when it comes to the legal defense, that's
what they go to. Alex Jones we know that Alex
Jones own lawyer or lawyers when he has been sued,
say This is an entertainer. He's doing a character
here. The things he says are in character. It's
it's almost like they liken it to, you know, when
I don't know when when Rufus Sewell plays a Nazi
in Men in the High Castle. That's not what Rufus
Sewell believes. It's his character. And like,
we all get it when we're watching men in the High
Castle. But it's deliberately kind of obfuscated
when it's Tucker Carlson or when it's Alex Jones
and Joe Rogan's. Using a different version of
that. He's not saying I'm playing a character.
He's just saying it should be obvious that it's
not smart to listen to me about this stuff.
But it's not obvious to the very people who
are actually going to listen and say, Oh, iverm